i know you want a shower and you want to
see chicago you want to have the day and
go to the park and flick the bean and a
miracle mile or whatever the hell it is
i'm sure there was still bean flicking
knowing this this rascal
yeah i can't find it no but yeah
you couldn't find the beans yeah i
couldn't find the bait
you know uh
that is why they made it so big ah
that's true that would help but uh you
hear about huge dicks where are the huge
clits
there's huge clits are there i mean okay
am i wrong pull them up i mean this is
we're really going to pollute this
google uh
oh my god jesus this is everything but
clips these are just dicks
what the hell are you doing
no no it's not
it's got a wow it looks just like a dick
well a big [ __ ] looks like a little dick
wow
that's gross
oh
hatchet wound that is brutal
oh that made me sad back to the show
this is like just turning like shock
jock radio that yeah that took a turn
let's let's stop talking about flying
and let's looking at some clits
you guys want to see some kids um
yeah man the travel that's the bad thing
about i mean look it's great that you're
moving up to theaters it's but at the
same time you start moving to theaters
in these cool cities right and those are
the cities you want to hang in like
that's why i did a taping at a small
venue because i'm like i want to hang in
chicago it's a good point yeah you go to
syracuse you got all the time in the
world there's nothing there it's brutal
terrible city terrible my number one
least favorite really with a bullet damn
what about you and you'll get one there
yeah terrible place i mean i hate i
hated naples with a passion
i don't like
i mean obviously new york is tough it is
you get some diamonds in the rough like
you know but
rochester has like a cool block yeah one
cool block but you're gonna get shot on
the on your way to that cool block right
buffalo has a has this hockey team and
some stuff i guess football football
they poured all their money into an
arena
it is hilarious when when cities are
dealing with drug problems and
homelessness and they're like we got a
new arena i know right better merch
well you i remember do you you're young
enough they're old enough to remember
that what barclays was before barclays
that was like a cool brooklyn area back
then yeah but now it's all gone well
yeah i don't like barclays i don't
either i don't think it's a cool arena
i've been to games there i i think the
arena is like it's
it's not awful but it's just not the
garden it's steep it's weird it's like
uh it's one of those things if you're
seated high up
it looks like you trip and you're dead
yeah you know which i [ __ ] hate when
and what is the nets i mean i'm not i'm
not the biggest dude they're imploding
right now what does that mean i mean
basically kyrie irving who knows if it's
all show but you know he had the whole
issue with the vax during the season
right which like just get it for your
teammates like these guys
will do anything to win and then he's
like i'm taking a moral stance i'm like
but you're not because there's people
who can't get it for their job and
you're super rich right so so the moral
stance is kind of like i get what you
think you're doing but then
now so he basically is the reason they
were i guess the seven or eight seed so
they had to play the celtics in the
first round
he
they're they haven't played together so
they're rusty they get swept wow so it's
embarrassing for a team with kevin
durant and kyrie irving to get swept
because they're both incredible players
damn they're thin whatever so now kyrie
wants like he wants a big contract
renegotiation
and
the team's kind of like [ __ ] you
but then it's like if he leaves
then durant's gonna want out
so they're basically falling apart and
they just you know we'll see but it is
as a knicks fan is it's i take great
pleasure yeah the misfortune of the
brooklyn nets i i'm with you because i'm
not a huge nba guy but i'm like we have
the knicks let's embrace the knicks they
should have gone to the knicks yes and
they didn't and i and forever i will be
mad about that but whatever it feels
like you got a wife or a husband and
then we just ah let's get a side chick
and see how that goes and now that's
falling apart and we're like well of
course we had the wife
yeah the problem with the knicks is
their practice facilities in westchester
so people don't want to come
i mean i get that you move to the city
and then they're like we practice in
connecticut right westchester is new
york but it feels like connecticut it
does it does it's a suburb yeah have you
been there have i been to west chester
i've never been to westchester my entire
life like whatever okay just houses and
driveways
yeah it's like it's not new york right i
yeah i've had friends who are from there
and stuff but it's like you know nick
nick is he yeah he's from westchester
all i think about is mauricio when i oh
when i when i hear westchester now
that's a deep pool
it's whatever it's not
no disrespect to our westchester
listeners but some say the best chester
i like cities
yeah same same but you know you get old
you had a family
but you could never i couldn't do that
yeah i'm a city kid through and through
every we have a good friend i don't want
to put him on blast here but he's this
he's a born and raised city guy he just
moved to the suburbs
and he's like my place is great i'm
miserable nah
do i got a kid though maybe i could
oh i didn't know he lived in the brook
yeah he moved to the burbs that hurts
the street cred a little huh
he's pretty uh he's pretty unhappy yeah
i mean look you get the comfort you get
the big couch with the tv and the man
cave and the big bedroom and the yard
but
you open the door and it's just cricket
cricket i'm not sure like the comfort
just hurts your comedy though because
not only are you comfortable but you're
far from the city now so it's like
that's two strikes against you yeah why
would you come to new york when you got
a sick
tv and a sick you know
movie set up whatever great chairs no
homeless no subway
i mean i read a groucho marx's book and
he lived out in long island you know
this is an upper east side jewish guy
from back in the day vaudeville moved to
long island as a millionaire he's a
hollywood legend comedy legend and they
go groucho you got this beautiful family
beautiful wife huge mansion pool golf
course
how do you feel he goes i'd give it all
up for one erection
[Laughter]
for one direction
the gig but that's kind of how i feel
about the city i thought he was gonna
say for one for a one bedroom like in
the city oh yeah yeah cause like i
really feel that we were like i mean
people were like what are you mad paying
this much for a tiny apartment i'm like
what are you mad living in a mansion in
indianapolis exactly you think that's
good and sure we get stabbed on the
subway but these [ __ ] are uh
their wives kill them with battery acid
over four years they put in the oatmeal
yeah it keeps you it keeps you limber
yes nothing keeps you on your that that
is good that like not being able to
totally space out yeah right you gotta
have a head on a swivel yeah that keeps
you like seinfeld always says like new
york city is just funny the cab driver
is funny the people on the subway are
funny the deli guy's funny you go to la
and everybody's like hey man do you
wanna fish taco
throw me that frisbee whoa the energy
makes it so you can't really suffer
fools yeah
like there's a quickness to the city
yeah like they're there's a guy who's
like from colin quinn's uh old
neighborhood billy who works at gotham
and he's so funny and he like literally
he's like one of those dudes who you're
like this dude's not a comic but he's
funnier than anything exactly he's one
of those dudes if we had him on this
podcast we'd be laughing
yes every story is like so then i call
the guy a [ __ ] [ __ ] and you're just
like i don't even know what he's talking
about but it's funny yeah yeah exactly i
grew up with guys like that they're all
firemen now but they're way funnier than
all of us and they're wild that's a job
where you have to be funny yeah for sure
high stress jobs
that's right you kind of have to be you
have to be they got their down time with
the foosball the chili
you know they clean the truck the
dalmatian but man
they could die at any moment yes that's
like the
i mean what a crazy life that's why you
ever do a cop gig or a firehouse or
they're the best laughers because you
cannot offend them you can't offend
themselves unless you say something
about their mistress
no you're trump
you can't offend i mean i'll say that i
was just in tampa you can't offend these
people no i did uh although i do have a
story but i'll save it for the other app
all right uh i dude you can't offend
people in tampa well you can be like i
like abortions and they're like we're
still laughing oh really i opened with i
was like how many dead baby and car
jokes can i open with i went for like
five to seven minutes what's going on
with you this is like a new uh page in
the sam well we were just watching news
and every story was like another baby in
a calm like who are these people really
yeah it happens all the time dude damn
yeah my issue is it's always the [ __ ]
people who are you know
who are pro-life
it's like you're pro-life but you're
[ __ ] but you i guess you can't resist
the sale at walmart i don't know what
the hell is going on you're for abortion
just later late late term later yeah
yeah there you go i mean you're leaving
a kid in a i mean think about how
[ __ ] dumb you have to be yeah to
because all the stories are like it was
three hours i'm like you left a kid in a
car
for three hours damn three hours that's
a lot that's a lot of shopping i mean
there's only so much dip you can buy
yeah but no walmart's got a lot of stuff
that's true you've got a lot of sections
there's sporting goods there's groceries
there's clothing yeah by the time you
get the baby clothes you're probably
like [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah when i was a kid we used to hotbox
but this is ridiculous all right
i remember the boxcar children but this
is ridiculous
remember those books yeah yeah my mom
would leave me in the car but she'd
crack the window that was the rule you
crack it yeah
though i mean yeah that's [ __ ] brutal
i mean it was the trunk but still
all right the trunk
i'm a trunk supporter trunk 2024
that hooker's still in mind but all
right
should we do questions oh [ __ ] i forgot
we have questions
michael's oh the old desi
when in an effort
[Music]